hi I'm sweet white my talk is called
computational public relations what
happens when we apply a computation
everywhere today I'm going to be talking
about some methods in social network
analysis and service connecting the
Wolfram language to see how we can use
computation to better public relations
outreach and messaging
joining me for my talk this afternoon
thank you for coming to the Wolfram
technology conference my name is sweet
white I work in the public relations
department at Wolfram research a media
and communications specialists meaning
largely I deal with external press
relations and things of that nature
today I'm going to be talking about
computational public relations the
subtitle is what happens when we apply
computation everywhere it has two
meanings here one public relations is
not typically thought of a technical
field where we're going to be using a
ton of computation a ton of programming
and things like that the other meaning
is part of our job in public relations
is to spread the message what happens
when we apply computation everywhere
especially through both firm products a
little bit about me before we begin
prior to joining Wolfram I was a
doctoral student in sociology at
Louisiana State University studying
social networks and identity formation
through social networks through that
theoretical lens I also worked in public
media at an NPR affiliate in Baton Rouge
for a little while so I've been on the
kind of journalism side of public
relations and now I'm on the other side
of the glass dealing with journalists so
the field of public relations is kind of
lagged behind marketing the two are kind
of intertwined marketing is a little bit
more they have in the past employed more
methods like AV testing really brought
in some of the scientific method into
what they do to get their message out
into the world
public relations some might describe it
a little bit more fluffy than marketing
but these two things are starting to
emerge with the emergence of things like
influencer marketing it's becoming more
and more difficult to tell the
difference between a purse of content
that you're reading on the web or in a
newspaper and a piece of marketing
material so when public relations comes
in and we're dealing with media and
putting out content to media we're
starting to use some of these marketing
methods in public relations also the
democratization of access to data and
computational methods is making it
easier for someone who's less technical
like me to use some of these methods
from data science to kind of get our
message out there measure success a
little bit better and figure out who to
target when how and why so first I'm
to talk about what is public relations
even though it kind of describes you a
little bit example one I'm gonna use
service connect with Wolfram language
are any of you familiar with service
connects and Wolfram language just two
of you awesome ok all right they're
gonna look at Twitter and then also a
trade show a social network of trade
show influencers we're gonna have a
brief model of information diffusion so
the Wolfram language defines where
relations as a promotion intended to
create goodwill for a person or
institution
I like the goodwill part of that because
in public relations we do try to have a
sense of ethics about us not being
manipulative not put something out there
that's going to be deceptive we always
try to be honest so Edward Bernays is
kind of a pioneer in the field of public
relations and he had three prongs to
public relations and one it's
information provided to the public just
in a pure form to its persuasion
directed at the public to modify
attitudes and actions so as you can
imagine ethics comes into play here when
we're trying to modify people's behavior
to do something and then finally efforts
to integrate attitudes and actions of an
institution with its publics and a
public's with that institution so as I
mentioned earlier traditional media and
advertising are becoming less important
with the advent of social and new media
and especially with influencer marketing
and research shows us that face-to-face
and word-of-mouth influence are still
crucial to spreading that information
kind of contradictory to this importance
of social media so it's still important
for us to get out there into the world
and deal with people face-to-face in
example 3 I'm going to show you how
that's important and how we can possibly
measure that so as I mentioned Edward
Bernays he wrote a book called
propaganda that was one of the first
general expositions on the art of
persuading large groups of people
propaganda has kind of a bad rap these
days and that's not necessarily for bad
reason but propaganda the word itself
actually comes from Pope Gregory the
15th in 1622 when he created a
Congregation for propagating the faith
so really the the core of the word is
any practice to propagate an ideology or
practice and for us that's the Wolfram
language
and using double from language so how
long is public relations existed when we
look at marketing propaganda and
advertising we see a spike beginning in
the early 20th century and Edward
Bernays was writing around that time and
what's interesting we see propaganda
decreasing with marketing and
advertising increasing do what you will
with that so a first example service
connect reddit so for those of you
unfamiliar with service connect
basically we have a built in function
that uses various api's and very easy to
understand way so if you're using
another program language and accessing
Redditt api you're going to have to do a
fairly extensive amount of programming
with Wolfram language we can do
something as simple as service connect
Reddit and there we have it
so what I'm going to do here is grab
some comments from and ask ask me
anything from reddit is everyone here
familiar with asking me anything on
reddit yes anyone not familiar okay so
basically on reddit which is kind of a
social not quite a social network but a
kind of a social interaction forum
people of note can go on this platform
and say i am stephen wolfram ask me
anything and people can ask questions
and so Stephen respond to these
questions I believe he's done three of
these this one in particular we're going
to be examining is about his latest book
idea makers okay so what we do is we
grab comments and we're going to use the
similarities function using nearest and
what we're gonna do is take each of the
questions people have asked and clumped
these together in a network so we can
more easily discern what people are
interested in knowing from Stephen
Wolfram so once we have our network
these are sized each node is sized by
their popularity so the more upvotes
a comment got the larger the node size
we've also used community graph plot
here to kind of more easily visualize
these various clumps so the most popular
is someone saying there's a huge fan
spent a lot of time huge gamut of
personalities then has a kind of
interesting question about richard
fineman
at the bottom another person asking
about the commonality between legendary
mathematician
scientists from ages ago and more modern
scientists and then we go over here we
have a question about is writing about
all these intelligent people did you
notice any environmental factors which
may have contributed to their success
why is Elon Musk's not included in the
book well it's 30 meters per second in
kilometres per second I think that's a
query better direct fit Wolfram Alpha
and hi Steven any inspiration words so
we have a wide variety of topics here
and I chose this one because it's
smaller and for the purposes of this
presentation it's kind of easier to show
you what's going on but in some of
Stephens other ama's there are many more
questions many more comments and if you
look at other subreddit so you can grab
interesting information and I should
note for the purposes of this
presentation I'm using things that are
Wolfram syndrome I don't want to sit
here and do an analysis of a competitor
and feel like oh this is what we're
doing in public relations so all right
so what we can do from there is use
built a building classifier which is
sentiment so we have a fairly decent
built in machine learning classifier
first intimate in Wolfram language and
so most of them are neutral we have a
little bit more negative than positive
which you know ok we also have an
interesting classifier that's by topic
and so a couple years ago we had this
thing called a facebook data donor
program and so a lot of people donated a
bunch of data from their Facebook feeds
and so what we did is take a lot of
status updates and we labeled them and
we categorized them and we came up with
a bunch of different categories that we
have been turned into a classifier you
can see here at classify Facebook topic
this is a huge time-saver and so
unsurprisingly most of these comments
are about books since it's about idea
makers we aren't too terribly surprised
there so next we're gonna look at
Twitter and this works in a similar
method just simply Service Connect
Twitter the parameters are fairly simple
and we're gonna look at Wolfram research
first the Wolfram research Twitter feed
so we get some basic information
location our follower count friends
count favorite counts
then we can look at our tweet strings
and we're gonna create a word cloud of
the let's see we have the last four
thousand tweets from Wolfram research
and so as you can see Wolfram is right
there Wolfram tech conference this is
interesting because it's a most most
recent thing we've been tweeting about
then we have our social media managers
initials right here because she signs
some of our tweets when we're doing
customer service type responses to
people that are mentioning us on Twitter
so we can also examine recent hashtags
and while we're looking at Wolfram
research you can imagine if you were
looking at other people that are on
Twitter this might become interesting
from a public relations perspective so
most recently we've had wolf Lang which
is unsurprising well from tech
conference Wolfram language tips
exploding dots I'm not sure what that is
and software design software design is
largely from yes-mo Matt talk
excellent good all right so we can do
the same thing again looking at
sentiment analysis for our tweets and
it's good to know that what we're
sending out into the world is mostly
positive or at least the machine
learning algorithm thinks it's mostly
positive we're now putting negativity
out into the world although there's a
little bit of indeterminate here we
could go in further and I figure out
what that is
so we can also do something similar that
we did with Reddit as far as a graph but
what we're doing here is looking at a
follower mention Network so these are
our followers that mention each other on
Twitter so right here we have Wolfram
research and we can see who's mentioning
Wolfram out of the people that we follow
unsurprisingly it's Wolfram Events
Christian Pascal he is actually the
person who works on our service connect
features so the things I'm showing you
today this is him and his team's a lot
of their hard work and then Christian
Rodriguez he used to be a student
ambassador of ours now he is with the
computational thinking initiative a
Wolfram success story and this is Vitaly
I'm sure some of you who know Wolfram
have heard of him and Clayton Sean Wyler
if you've ever been on Wolfram community
and you've seen any of the amazing gifts
mathematical gifts that are on there
it's probably Clayton that has made some
of them so these are the people
mentioning Wolfram and then over here we
have a Nassim Nicholas Taleb who this
person Murray do me trova has mentioned
so he's kind of loosely connected which
is interesting because he does interact
with Wolfram products a lot so then we
have periscope National Geographic
Twitter video and periscope TV and then
we have all these sad lonely people here
and that's just merriam-webster and
Twitter and Tumblr who are not
mentioning us or one another all right
so another thing we can do is look at
when Wolfram research or any other
Twitter user tweets most so what we see
for Wolfram research is around 9:30 10
o'clock we're tweeting a lot and it
falls off throughout the day
occasionally we tweet at 3 o'clock in
the morning apparently and then also the
day of the week so Wednesday's our most
popular for us
Mondays I guess we have the Blues on
Monday and then all weekends were not to
eating too much so we can also look at
all the time counts I found this really
interesting going back to July 14th how
often we've been tweeting and as you can
see there's a huge outlier here
and I guess back at the tech conference
back in the 14th we were live tweeting
the tech conference to something to the
tune of like 70 tweets in a day or
something like that which is a lot one
other thing we can do is explore certain
hashtags on Twitter so we don't have to
use just hashtags we can use any kind of
phrase we can look at users we can use
it any kind of mentions on Twitter I
thought it'd be interesting just to pull
up machine learning as an example so as
you can see here the code is very simple
so we've defined Twitter earlier with
service connect and we're just doing
tweet search query machine learning and
I'm just going to pull 100 items I think
we can pull up to 5,000 I would have to
check Twitter's API there is a max limit
to how many you can pull it once so what
we've done is create a network again
with tooltip and so we can look and
these are sized by the way the bigger
the node this is the more retweets these
have gotten so it's kind of a proxy to
measure how popular they are we can also
look at favorite counts as well so we
see this fellow over here has someone's
RTing this fellow how our artificial
intelligence can deliver a personalized
banking experience and that see we see
the financial services tweet which is
very similar with fin tech and then
solutions can support city geo plans and
we see these self loops because these
are very these loops are here because
these are very similar tweets so this
person deep learn double-oh-seven seems
to be some sort of influencer with
machine learning on twitter which would
be interesting to explore more there he
is again and then we have these kind of
sad lonely people all these sad little
tweets over here it's kind of hanging
out so what we can do again is use our
classifier to see what categories these
fall into and machine learning under
that hashtag unsurprisingly technology
well it was surprising to me there was
video games so it'd be interesting to go
into the class of the Facebook
classifier and see why it's categorizing
these machine learning tweets into video
games what is
about them that is thinks are related to
video games so we can also look at CEO
analysis on Twitter and look at Stephen
Wolfram and what people are saying about
Stephen Wolfram on Twitter again we have
a very simple query and I've actually
I've queried his actual Twitter handle
because I want to see what people are
how they're mentioning him here and so
first what I've done is use some code
here
to take the top words most significant
words out of streams on Twitter that
people are saying about him and so we
have physicists make great
entrepreneurship and an entrepreneurs
when I first saw that I giggled because
someone published an article talking
about how physicists make really great
entrepreneurs and it seems to be going
strong for about three or four weeks now
and it just keeps popping up and our
analytics so I thought that was
interesting obviously we could go in if
we want to get rid of that we could put
that in our delete our stop words right
so then we could get rid of those and
see what else is going on but we also
have startup story that's actually
related to that tweet video I'm not sure
if all of you are aware if you heard in
Stevens keynote he is doing a lot of
twitch broadcasts if you're not familiar
with twitch there's a live streaming
platform so Steven if he is sitting down
late in the evening to do some coding
some research he will hit start
streaming and you can tune in with him
he's also been streaming some meetings
design review meetings which is
interesting we weren't sure how that
would go over live streaming meetings
well from research but we've gotten a
lot of good feedback from it so we can
go in and look at some of the tweets so
we have some feedback where is it out
over here no that's not it
so this is when he was in Scotland just
this past weekend he was giving the
keynote at the Darcy Thompson on growth
in forum at 100 conference there was
some feedback on twitch here we go
so feedback on Twitter people tweeting
about a software design live live
streaming internal design review
then something about arrival then people
watching him on Twitch so again we can
classify these pretty easily
and very happy to see that there are
more positives than negatives about
Stephen on Twitter always good and then
it's categorizing these it's mostly
about television my suspicion is that
because of twitch because he's
mentioning video so much that it's
categorizing these things into
television then also videogames because
twitch is largely used for streaming
video games
the last example I want to show you is
probably the most interesting its
conference attendees social networks and
information diffusion so let's say I
have lists of potential Wolfram language
evangelists or influencers that attend
different conferences and I have these
separate lists what I want to do is
combine those lists and then come up
with some sort of Association matrix so
I can figure out who in this list is the
most important who should i target who
should I give information to so that
they'll share that information right and
so one way that we go about not making
sure but encouraging people to share
information is to tell them a secret
because have you ever told someone a
secret before you've probably noticed
that they tell other people that secrets
so I don't want to go so far as to call
it a leak of information but one of the
I guess more dark arts of public
relations would be maybe telling people
some secrets so first we have all these
lists and we have to wrangle the data
this is probably the most boring part of
doing this type of work but it has to be
done fortunately Wolfram language makes
it pretty easy so as you can see in our
data structure I have some various
conferences then I have a name and then
zeros and ones indicating if they attend
attended that conference or plan to
attend that conference so what I want to
do is change that into boolean true
false values to make it cleaner and
easier and create give column when a
header which is important when you have
a name header there and create an
association and so what this does is
this gives us a really nice data set so
that we can then query
so what we're gonna do first is create a
network at the conference level so I'm
assuming everyone here is familiar with
social networks that's kind of big that
down a little bit so each node
represents a conference each red node
represents a conference and each line in
there represents a connection to that
conference from these attendees so as
you can see I have strata here SIGGRAPH
CES south-by-southwest
collision jsm JMM tech week and disrupt
so what we can then do is manipulate
this graph a little bit so I want to
know which one of these conferences have
the most influencers going to it so what
we can do is create another graph and
I'm gonna use color data here so that
the brightest colored node of the
conference this is the one that has the
most vertices so the most lines which
translates into conference attendees so
it's a really quick easy way to
visualize this and so you can see South
by Southwest and collision are the most
popular among our attendees or
influencers so what we can do next is go
down to the person level so we're gonna
create an adjacency matrix and so we
have all of our conference attendees
here we can see these clusters right
here so we can see these people are more
connected among all of these conferences
so these might be people that I'm more
interested in giving information to than
others some of these more outlier folks
that really aren't very connected so we
have in network science and social
network analysis we have various
measures of what we call centrality and
basically what that means is how
embedded someone is in the network based
on shortest paths between vertices that
pass through that vertex ok so what we
can do again is use color data to look
at who has the highest betweenness
centrality right and so this really
starts to narrow things down especially
when you see this person right here we
also have a pinwheel of death
so what we can do is then make a quick
function to tell us who are these top
five people and by the way these are
fake names obviously that was supposed
to be I was gonna name that person
Griffith but apparently I named him
Zachary Griffi D so we can see quickly
who has the highest betweenness
centrality we can seem like a pretty big
difference between this person and the
rest so this is someone that would I
would definitely flag as interesting
here we also have a closeness centrality
which is slightly different but as you
can see it's not quite as good of a
measure because look at how close not to
confine but how close all these colors
are together but one other measure we
have is eigenvector centrality which is
a little bit better here so what we can
see is we have our same person here if
that's let's see okay we have the same
person here john whitney when we confirm
that right here and again we can see
this person has a pretty substantially
higher ican vector centrality than the
others so what we can do then is take
John Whitney and put him in a
neighborhood graph to see exactly how
he's connecting to all these conferences
and not surprisingly he plans to attend
all of them so this person might be
someone I would be more interested in
giving information to rather than one of
these outliers so what I'm gonna do
finally is look at a little bit of
information diffusion and how to model
that so what I'm gonna do is use an
epidemiological model and have a coin
toss probability that someone that
interacts with the neighbor is going to
spread that information we can change
that probability depending on how juicy
our information is or something like
that
one of the difficulties with measuring
things like this is it's really
difficult like let's say I tell someone
a secret how am I going to effectively
and scientifically measure how that
secret spread there are some ways that I
can think of but it's not exactly going
to be robust right so the best thing
that we can do is model it and try to
figure out what might happen so I'm
gonna do is start off with a random
graph
and this is a small world network if you
have not heard a small world grass
you've probably heard of six degrees of
separation yes okay yeah so this is this
type of network that it is an
interestingly they're also found in C
elegans worm brains which I thought was
an interesting tidbit about small world
networks so as you can see we start off
with our red node and this is someone
I've given information to you and after
one step here's how many people have
potentially received that information
after several steps we have this network
with all the infected yellow nodes that
we're gonna call it so then we can model
this with the manipulate and see how
this might play out over certain
iterations so as you can see it happens
fairly quickly in a small world network
and it's worth pointing out that all not
all networks or small world networks our
real life networks are social networks a
lot of them happen to be however not all
of them are so the network that I just
showed with all of my conference
attendees we can test to see if it's a
small world network and we can also plug
that into here to measure for example if
I gave John Whitney a piece of
information we can then model how likely
it is that that information is going to
spread through that network again very
difficult to measure
so with that questions comments
suggestions you can also use the person
connect function to connect with me on
LinkedIn Twitter and contact me by email
yes yes I'll build it yes
yeah so so what happens is when you when
you use a lot of explainin rather than
show so what happens when you when you
run that piece of code it'll open a web
browser and so what's very cool is that
instead of having to have your key for
your Twitter account you will need a
reddit account or a Twitter account
right so what's interesting instead of
having to have that API key we have
something called Wolfram connector and
what it does is opens a web browser and
it just asks for your odds s for
authorization to access the Twitter API
or the reddit API through your account
you just press ok and you go back to
Wolfram language and you're good to go
with all the different API calls
so the Reddit and Twitter API calls and
Wolfram language are in the
documentation it's pretty extensive
mm-hmm no notes all of its so there's
rate limits aside from that they're
there of no costs they're built into the
Wolfram language oh yes
it
yeah there are about 10 centrality
measures and go from language if I
recall correctly the best one to use
would be between the centrality for the
purposes of social network analysis
eigenvector centrality has a little bit
slightly more robust to algorithm
however it's less commonly used in
social network analysis in my experience
dead all of that is in the documentation
and outlined there like quite extensive
[Applause]